This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Picture with me, if you will, India during British colonial rule. Let's say around the year 1865. Picture a government office in Bombay, as the city was then known. Two British officers are discussing an uprising that has been challenging Britain's sovereignty over the subcontinent. It's May, the hottest month in India. Temperatures have soared to over 100 degrees Fahrenheit. The officers are sweating. There's no air conditioning, of course, but they have a servant who brings them two ice cold drinks. The officers take sips of their drinks and swirl the ice in their glasses. And at this moment, these cold drinks dripping with condensation. Feel like a small miracle to these colonialist wankers.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。请和我一起想象一下，英国殖民统治时期的印度。假设是在1865年左右。想象一下孟买（当时这座城市的称呼）的一间政府办公室。两名英国官员正在讨论一场挑战英国对次大陆主权的起义。那是五月，印度最热的月份。气温飙升至华氏100度以上。官员们汗流浃背。当然，没有空调，但他们有一名仆人，为他们端来了两杯冰镇饮料。官员们啜饮着饮料，摇晃着杯中的冰块。在那一刻，这些挂着冷凝水的冰镇饮料，对这些殖民主义混蛋来说，简直就像一个小小的奇迹。
But actually, the ice was a kind of miracle. That's our own little miracle, Sam Greensman. Because in 1865, no one had refrigerators. It wouldn't be for another half century until they started appearing in the US, little lone India. Think about the ice in those officers' glasses. If you were to zoom out from those glasses, and out, and out, and then zoom in on the United States, on Boston, on a frozen lake in the dead of winter.
但实际上，冰确实是一种奇迹。那是我们自己的小奇迹，萨姆·格林斯潘。因为在1865年，没有人有冰箱。直到半个世纪后，冰箱才开始在美国出现，更不用说印度了。想想那些官员杯子里的冰。如果你把镜头从那些杯子上拉远，再拉远，再拉远，然后聚焦到美国，聚焦到波士顿，聚焦到严冬里结冰的湖面上。
There, you'd find men working. You see a lot of men and horses and a lot of activity going on, and then you'll see horse-drawn plows, pikes and pusher bars or poles. That's Rick Smith, amateur historian of the American ice trade. So all of these people together were on the lake harvesting ice. Workers would cut ice out of a frozen pond, haul it to port, put it on a ship, and send it on a four-month journey to India. Any ice that British officers in colonial India would have had in their drinks would have started out on the top of a pond in Massachusetts. The tools of the ice trade varied by location, but generally it went like this.
在那里，你会发现工人们在工作。你会看到很多工人和马匹，还有很多活动正在进行，然后你会看到马拉的犁、长矛和推杆或杆子。那是里克·史密斯，美国冰块贸易的业余历史学家。所以所有这些人都在湖上收割冰块。工人们会把冰从结冰的池塘里切下来，运到港口，装上船，然后进行为期四个月的印度之旅。英国驻印度殖民官员杯子里的任何冰块，最初都来自马萨诸塞州的一个池塘表面。冰块贸易的工具因地而异，但大体上是这样的。
So the first step is to measure the ice. There's a small drill hole that's drilled in and a measurement taken of how thick the ice is because it had to be at least 14 inches thick. 14 inches of ice was thick enough to hold the team of workers and horses that would be assembled, starting usually the day after a Christmas. The workers would come out onto the ice, clear off snow and debris, and then- The horse-drawn ice plows would start to score the ice,
第一步是测量冰层。钻一个小孔，测量冰的厚度，因为它必须至少有14英寸厚。14英寸厚的冰足以支撑起通常在圣诞节后第二天组建的工人和马匹队伍。工人们会来到冰面上，清理积雪和杂物，然后——马拉的冰犁开始在冰面上刻线，
and they would do this all over the ice until they had made a grid. A grid on the ice. They could have make a checkerboard, let's say. Workers would use giant hand saws and ice pikes, basically big sticks with sharp ends, to break up the squares of ice so that they were floating in the water. A steam-powered conveyor belt would haul these cakes of ice out of the water, and they would go through a planer, so each cake would become smooth and uniform.
他们会在整个冰面上这样做，直到形成一个网格。冰面上的网格。我们可以说他们做了一个棋盘。工人们会使用巨大的手锯和冰矛（基本上是带有尖头的大棍子）来破碎冰块，使它们漂浮在水中。蒸汽驱动的传送带会将这些冰块从水中运出，然后通过刨冰机，使每块冰都变得光滑均匀。
Then, they'd be stacked in a nearby ice house, a large wooden structure that would hold tons of ice. Ice houses often had a railroad siding, so the ice could be loaded up onto a train and freight it off to the city. If you've seen the Disney movie Frozen, the ice harvesting scene is actually pretty accurate. At its peak, ice harvesting happened on lakes all over New England, New York, Michigan, in the Poconos region of Northeastern Pennsylvania. It was, at one time, the major industry. My father actually worked on the ice harvesting back in the 1930s and 40s, and even into the 50s. This entire area of the Poconos,s and even into the 50s. This entire area of the Poconos, that was pretty much the only thing that you could do
然后，它们会被堆放在附近的冰窖里，那是一个可以容纳数吨冰块的大型木结构建筑。冰窖通常有铁路侧线，这样冰块就可以装上火车运往城市。如果你看过迪士尼电影《冰雪奇缘》，里面的冰块收割场景其实相当准确。在鼎盛时期，冰块收割发生在整个新英格兰、纽约、密歇根和宾夕法尼亚州东北部的波科诺地区。它曾经是一个主要的产业。我父亲实际上在20世纪30年代和40年代，甚至到50年代都在从事冰块收割工作。波科诺的整个地区，这几乎是你在冬天唯一能做的工作。
in the winter time for work. But now it's gone. It just disappeared entirely. It's a bit sad in a way that an industry, a multi-deway, as it were. Here to also remember the natural ice industry, is Gavin Waitman. I'm Gavin Waitman. I live in London, and I write social history books mainly. And one of my most successful books was called the Frozen Water Trade. One edition of the book is actually titled
但现在它消失了。它完全消失了。某种程度上，一个产业的消亡令人难过，这是一种多维度的消亡。同样来纪念天然冰产业的还有加文·韦特曼。我是加文·韦特曼。我住在伦敦，主要写社会历史书籍。我最成功的书之一叫《冷冻水贸易》。这本书的一个版本实际上标题为
The Frozen Water Trade, a true story. Maybe because even Gavin's publishers thought the prospect of cutting frozen water out of American lakes and shipping it overseas Sounded made up. But that is exactly what happened. Ice was being harvested from all over the American Northeast packed onto railroad cars and ships and sent out to the southern US, the Caribbean, and British colonists in India. The development of the international ice trade can be traced back to one person, a man who, by the end of his life, would come to be known as the Ice King, a guy named Frederick Tudor. He was the son of a modestly well-off Boston family.
《冷冻水贸易：一个真实的故事》。也许是因为连加文的出版商都认为，从美国湖泊中切割冷冻水并将其运往海外的前景听起来像是编造的。但那正是发生的事情。冰块从整个美国东北部被收割，装上火车和船只，运往美国南部、加勒比地区和印度的英国殖民者手中。国际冰块贸易的发展可以追溯到一个人，一个在他生命结束时被称为“冰王”的人，名叫弗雷德里克·都铎。他是波士顿一个中产家庭的儿子。
I think it'd be a very old bloke, sorry I shouldn't use the word bloke, it's an English stuff. So, basically I think he'd be a very old bloke, sorry I shouldn't use the word bloke, it's an English stuff. So, I think he'd be pretty eccentric bloke. Now, Tudor did not invent the idea of moving frozen water from one place to another. The practice actually began in Europe and South America, well before Tudor's time. People would go up to the mountains and bring down ice and snow. Although Tudor might not have known about this, but he did know that New Englanders had a local tradition of cutting ice out of local lakes and using it to keep food cool. When Fridet Tudor was a young man, farmers certainly did keep ice, which they
我想他应该是一个非常古怪的家伙，抱歉我不该用“家伙”这个词，这是英国式的说法。所以，基本上我认为他应该是一个非常古怪的家伙。现在，都铎并没有发明把冷冻水从一个地方运到另一个地方的想法。这种做法实际上在都铎时代之前很久就在欧洲和南美开始了。人们会去山上把冰雪带下来。虽然都铎可能不知道这一点，但他确实知道新英格兰人有一种从当地湖泊中切割冰块并用它来保持食物凉爽的传统。当弗雷德里克·都铎年轻时，农民们确实会保留冰块，他们
collected at the winter, and then when they were taking a bus at the market in the summer, they would take a bit of this ice in order to prevent it from melting. So it was used on a small scale in that way, but it wasn't put into drinks and that sort of thing, and it was very localised. When Tudor was in his early 20s, he and his brother William took a trip to the Caribbean. And he thought, these people need ice. Tudor's idea was that he was going to make his fortune because ice was a frozen asset of New England, it wasn't being used, and he felt he could sell it, particularly to countries which were very hot and could have no ice unless he delivered it to them from Boston lakes
在冬天收集冰块，然后在夏天去市场时，他们会带一点这种冰以防止它融化。所以它在那时是小规模使用的，但它并没有被放入饮料之类的东西中，而且非常局部化。当都铎20多岁时，他和他的兄弟威廉去了一趟加勒比海。他想，这些人需要冰。都铎的想法是他要发财，因为冰是新英格兰的冷冻资产，它没有被利用，他觉得他可以卖掉它，特别是卖给那些非常炎热、除非他从波士顿的湖泊中运送给他们否则就无法获得冰块的国家
and pods. And Bostonians thought he was absolutely crazy. But Tudor was convinced that this could work. Kaki even. He wrote that selling ice would make him quote, inevitably and unavoidably rich. Tudor set up shop on the banks of a pond called Fresh Pond in Cambridge, Massachusetts, just about two miles northwest of Harvard Square. And after he learned how to get ice out of the lake,
和池塘。波士顿人认为他绝对疯了。但都铎确信这行得通。他甚至写道，卖冰会使他“不可避免地、不可避免地富有”。都铎在马萨诸塞州剑桥市一个叫“淡水池”的池塘边开了店，就在哈佛广场西北约两英里处。在他学会了如何从湖中取出冰块后，
Tudor started looking for learned how to get ice out of the lake, Tutor started looking for new ways to keep ice frozen. Frederick Tutor experimented with all sorts of insulating materials, because remember, this was more than 100 years before refrigerators began appearing in people's houses. He discovered that sawdust was a remarkably good insulator, and he could get it for next to nothing
都铎开始寻找保持冰块冷冻的新方法。弗雷德里克·都铎尝试了各种绝缘材料，因为请记住，这比冰箱开始出现在人们家中早了100多年。他发现锯末是一种非常好的绝缘体，他几乎可以免费从缅因州的木材厂得到它
from lumber mills and Maine. Kept inside of a dry ice house and packed with sawdust, Tudor would eventually discover that he could keep ice stable for years. So all Tudor had to do was get the ice on to a ship and send it to hotter climates. His first attempt to sell ice outside Boston was made with a little shipment to Masanique. Shippers didn't want to ship ice. It seemed the most ridiculous cargo, so he fitted out a ship himself. The ice made it to the Caribbean no problem, but Martinique was not equipped to deal with a temperature-sensitive product that literally melts into something worthless without the
放在干燥的冰窖里并用锯末填充，都铎最终发现他可以保持冰块稳定多年。所以都铎所要做的就是把冰块装上船，送到更热的气候中。他第一次尝试在波士顿以外销售冰块是运往马提尼克岛的一小批货物。船运公司不想运送冰块。这似乎是最荒谬的货物，所以他自己装备了一艘船。冰块毫无问题地到达了加勒比海，但马提尼克岛没有配备处理这种对温度敏感的产品，如果没有正确的设施，它会融化成毫无价值的东西。
right infrastructure. It was a bit of a failure really, because when it got to Mars, no one knew how to keep ice. He wrote a rather amusing entry in his diary about the fact that people wrapped their piece of ice in blankets and wanted off and wanted why to disappear when they got home. The newspapers ridiculed Tudor. But Tudor would not be discouraged. He went back to the Caribbean and to the Southern United States
这确实有点失败，因为当它到达马提尼克时，没有人知道如何保存冰块。他在日记中写下了一个相当有趣的条目，关于人们把冰块裹在毯子里，然后想知道为什么当他们回家时冰块消失了。报纸嘲笑都铎。但都铎并没有气馁。他回到了加勒比海和美国南部
and showed people there how to build more effective ice houses. And it worked. Frozen water carved out of lakes and ponds was being transported hundreds to thousands of miles. He had a rough time getting it going. He went bankrupt a couple of times, but he did manage it in the end. But for all of Tudor's innovation and installation and supply chain logistics, his true genius
并向那里的人们展示了如何建造更有效的冰窖。它奏效了。从湖泊和池塘中切割出来的冷冻水被运送了数百到数千英里。他在起步时经历了一段艰难的时期。他破产了几次，但他最终还是成功了。但对于都铎所有的创新、绝缘和供应链物流，他真正的天才
was as a marketer. Before Tudor, ice had mostly just been used to preserve foodstuffs. Fredric Tudor pioneered the radical idea of putting ice into beverages. When you first drink a cold drink like that, when you were not used to it, it's quite a shock actually. So you had to persuade people that what he was selling was a luxury and worth paying for. Tudor would tout his eyes around to bars and so on, offer it from free. Say, look, try this, try that. He had to persuade people that what he was setting was a game to improve their
在于营销。在都铎之前，冰块主要只是用来保存食物。弗雷德里克·都铎开创了将冰块放入饮料中的激进想法。当你第一次喝这样的冷饮时，当你还不习惯时，这实际上是一个相当大的冲击。所以你必须说服人们，他卖的是一种奢侈品，值得花钱购买。都铎会把他的冰块推销到酒吧等地，免费提供。说，看，试试这个，试试那个。他必须说服人们，他所销售的是一种改善他们
lives, if you like. It wasn't self-evident to them. The first one, as they say, is always free. Tudor wrote, once people had tried chill drinks, they were hooked, and with no longer tolerate tepid water. He was a bit like a sort of drug pusher. And like any drug pusher, Tutor soon found himself with a lot of competition.
生活的东西，如果你愿意的话。这对他们来说并不是不言而喻的。正如他们所说，第一次总是免费的。都铎写道，一旦人们尝试了冰镇饮料，他们就上瘾了，再也无法忍受温水。他有点像个毒贩。像任何毒贩一样，都铎很快发现自己面临着很多竞争。
Rival ice company set up shop on Tutor's fresh pond and staked a claim to it. In fact, they had to go get a Harvard professor to devise a map carving up boundaries for the ice rights of different parties all on the same lake. And of course, it wasn't just fresh pond, because now anybody of water that was frozen thick enough to support the weight of an ice harvesting crew was a hot commodity. Ice began to get harvested all over New England and New York, Pennsylvania and Canada.
竞争对手的冰块公司在都铎的淡水池开了店，并宣称拥有所有权。事实上，他们不得不请一位哈佛教授设计一张地图，划分同一湖泊上不同方的冰块权利边界。当然，不仅仅是淡水池，因为现在任何结冰厚到足以支撑冰块收割队重量的水体都是热门商品。冰块开始在整个新英格兰、纽约、宾夕法尼亚和加拿大被收割。
One of Tutors competitors, the Wyndham Lake ice company based out of Wyndham Lake about 30 miles north of Boston, somehow they managed to persuade their buyers that their ice was premium product. Somehow, they managed to persuade their buyers that their ice was premium product. Ice from whenum lake would be sold as especially pure. It was nonsense, really, but it was a way of marketing, you know, our ice is better than yours. Legend has it that clean Victoria would only use whenum lake ice. And maybe you're thinking, why would England need to import ice all the way from North America when there are plenty of really cold places that are closer? Norway wondered the same thing. Norwegian businessmen tried breaking into the ice bizz, even going so far as to rename one of their lakes,
都铎的竞争对手之一，位于波士顿以北约30英里的温纳姆湖冰块公司，不知何故，他们成功说服买家他们的冰块是优质产品。温纳姆湖的冰块被作为特别纯净的产品出售。这其实是胡说八道，但这是一种营销方式，你知道，我们的冰块比你们的好。传说维多利亚女王只使用温纳姆湖的冰块。也许你在想，既然有那么多更近的真正寒冷的地方，英国为什么需要从北美进口冰块？挪威人也想到了同样的问题。挪威商人试图进入冰块行业，甚至不惜将他们的一座湖泊改名为
Wenham Lake, in an attempt to profit from the Wenham Lake ice companies' prestige and name recognition. Fregic Tutors Company never made a play for the UK ice market, which turned out to be a pretty good business move, because ice never really took off in England. Even in the 20th century, American GIs in England were shocked to find nothing but warm beer. And there were several in the Air Force who said they would put their drinks in the back of a plane and fly it to about 25,000 feet where it would chill a little bit at least. But there was one place where Brits could not get enough ice, India. So this is three months in the hold of a ship, twice across the equator. So it was quite a remarkable survival rate for the ice, which was eventually unloaded in Bombay as it was called then Madras and Calcasa. Despite all this, Frederick Tutor never really became inevitably an unavoidably rich, like he'd predicted. His whole life he was in and out of debt
温纳姆湖，试图从温纳姆湖冰块公司的声望和品牌知名度中获利。弗雷德里克·都铎的公司从未涉足英国冰块市场，这被证明是一个相当不错的商业举措，因为冰块在英国从未真正流行起来。即使在20世纪，英国的美国大兵也惊讶地发现只有温啤酒。空军里有几个人说他们会把饮料放在飞机后面，飞到大约25000英尺的高度，至少可以稍微冷却一下。但有一个地方英国人对冰块的需求供不应求，那就是印度。所以这是在船舱里三个月，两次穿过赤道。因此，冰块的存活率相当惊人，最终在孟买（当时被称为马德拉斯和加尔各答）卸货。尽管如此，弗雷德里克·都铎从未像他预测的那样变得不可避免地富有。他一生都在债务和债务人监狱中进进出出
and debtors' presence. And he eventually became not particularly wealthy, but well enough of, and he bought an estate outside Boston and lived a kind of rural life. But still, it wouldn't be until 40 years after Tutor's death, squarely in the 20th century, that the natural ice industry began to shift. The earliest refrigerators started appearing in the 19 teens, but the early models broke all the time. The physics of cooling proved much harder to master than heating, and of course you had to have electricity, which most homes in the US didn't have until the 1920s.
最终他并没有变得特别富有，但生活得还不错，他在波士顿郊外买了一处庄园，过着一种乡村生活。但即便如此，直到都铎去世40年后，也就是20世纪，天然冰产业才开始发生转变。最早的冰箱在1910年代开始出现，但早期的型号总是坏。事实证明，冷却的物理原理比加热更难掌握，当然你必须有电，而美国大多数家庭直到1920年代才有电。
Slowly but surely, the technology kept kept improving and consumers began to have a choice of getting natural ice scraped off the top of a frozen pond or ice made in a factory where the water could be better controlled and filtered. Which started to get more important because as the towns grew, as buildings grew up around fresh pond and the other lakes that we used for supply, sewage would get into them. It became a health hazard. This became a great problem for the natural ice industry. And to make matters worse for the natural ice trade, the Northeast experienced a spate of unusually warm winters. The ponds that have been supplying the world's ice weren't freezing as well. The newspapers were calling it an ice famine.
技术缓慢但肯定地不断进步，消费者开始有了选择：是选择从结冰的池塘表面刮下来的天然冰，还是选择在工厂里制造的冰，那里的水可以得到更好的控制和过滤。这变得越来越重要，因为随着城镇的发展，随着淡水池和其他我们用于供应的湖泊周围建筑物的兴起，污水会进入其中。这成了一种健康危害。这对天然冰产业来说是一个巨大的问题。更糟糕的是，对于天然冰贸易来说，东北部经历了一连串异常温暖的冬天。一直为世界供应冰块的池塘结冰情况不佳。报纸称之为“冰荒”。
The supply region shifted northward towards Maine, where the climate was colder and the water less polluted. But by then, the writing was on the wall. The natural ice trade was on its way out in the 1920s, but hung on in some places, especially rural places, until as late as the 1950s. And ice harvests still happen in some places. There's a renewed interest in the tradition. In Pennsylvania and all over New England,
供应区域向北转移到缅因州，那里气候更冷，水污染更少。但到那时，大势已去。天然冰贸易在1920年代走向衰落，但在一些地方，特别是农村地区，一直持续到1950年代。在某些地方，冰块收割仍然存在。人们对这一传统重新产生了兴趣。在宾夕法尼亚州和整个新英格兰，
there are some ice harvest revivals. One. But, you know, with some updated tools, and it's all more for heritage value. Two. All right. It's not like people are still putting frozen pond water in their drinks.
有一些冰块收割的复兴活动。一。但是，你知道，使用了一些更新的工具，这更多是为了遗产价值。二。好吧。并不是说人们还在把结冰的池塘水放进饮料里。
But as for the actual site where all of this started, fresh pond in Cambridge, Massachusetts, the ice trade might as well have never existed. When I was researching this story, I stayed up in Cambridge and I went out to fresh pond. People were jogging around the lake and they were confronted by me, this completely mad Englishman saying, excuse me, do you know that this ice used to be transported to India from this pond? And they looked at me as if I was completely mad. So at fresh pond there's no plaque or anything?
但至于这一切开始的实际地点，马萨诸塞州剑桥市的淡水池，冰块贸易简直就像从未存在过一样。当我研究这个故事时，我住在剑桥，去了淡水池。人们在湖边慢跑，他们遇到了我，这个完全疯狂的英国人说，打扰一下，你知道这个池塘的冰曾经被运往印度吗？他们看着我，好像我完全疯了一样。所以在淡水池没有牌匾之类的东西吗？
No. No. Cambridge, Massachusetts has finally found something to not commemorate with a plaque. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Sam Greenspan with Katie Mangle, Avery Truffman, Kirk Cole Stead, Delaney Hall, Sharifusef, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Rosie Weinberg, Stein, Yvara Loteida, and Dylan Garrett Smith, who reached out to us about this story. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arksign, an architecture and interiors firm. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook.
没有。没有。马萨诸塞州剑桥市终于找到了一个不值得用牌匾纪念的东西。《99%隐形》本周由萨姆·格林斯潘制作，凯蒂·曼格尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、柯克·科尔·斯特德、德莱尼·霍尔、谢里夫·尤塞夫和我罗曼·马斯参与。特别感谢罗西·温伯格、斯坦、伊瓦拉·洛泰达和迪伦·加勒特·史密斯，他们就这个故事联系了我们。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在Arksign（一家位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑和室内设计公司）的办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。
The show's Twitter is at 999PI, org, and my Twitter is at Roman Mars. Make sure you tag me if you have a picture of a coin that you'd like to share. We're all on Instagram, Tumblr, and Spotify too. But this week, your mission is to spend some quality time with the new beautifultapio.org There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
节目的Twitter是@999PI，org，我的Twitter是@RomanMars。如果你有想分享的硬币照片，一定要标记我。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Spotify上。但本周，你的任务是花点时间浏览新的beautifultapio.org。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。